my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure
you know the rest I saved the city fell
in love then I saved the city again and
again and again look I'm a comic book
serial I get a Christmas album and it's
so so popsicle but this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once the day zip
zap zop in his little mask and answers
to no one I love you ma are you serious
dad I love you better gosh
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm the one and
only spider-man at least that's what I
thought you'll be here for supercollider
you're gonna love this
you're like me that's impossible
alright kid listen up this part is your
universe soggy it's weird it's gross and
this delicious normal fry is my universe
so you want to learn to be spider-man
Keeney teacher yes I can time to swing
good double tap to release and twist it
out again whip and release your natural
quit hey guys who are you I'm Gwen Stacy
I'm from another another dimension
how many more spider people are there
hey tell us this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weird we need to
get back to our universes soon Cocoa's
go to collapse my family lives in
Brooklyn
was never your city
[Music]
it's mine
if I don't destroy the collider none of
us will have a home to go home soon
remember what makes you different let's
go is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait do animals talk
in this dimension cuz I don't want to
freak him out
[Music]
[Applause]
you